Donald Trump is what in the world of
poker or chess we call on tilt because
of the widespread reporting of these
truly terrible polling numbers that have
been released over the last 10 days or
so and I'll remind you once again
according to Donald Trump's own internal
polling and public polls as of right now
Donald Trump is losing badly in some key
2020 battleground states he's fired some
pollsters just reported that to you in
the last story he's called the polls
fake he's done everything under the Sun
to try to suppress the news of those
polls but now he is even calling Fox
News fake news this is getting very very
interesting Bret Baier on Fox News did
something which is not really a huge
deal
Bret Baier just reported what the polls
are saying including this new Fox News
poll that I told you about yesterday
which says Trump is down by nine to
Bernie and by 10 to Joe Biden in
hypothetical 2020 matchups and because
bret baier merely said we did a poll in
here's what it says
Donald Trump immediately took to Twitter
and attacked Bret Baier for spreading
fake news tweeting quote Fox News polls
are always bad for me that's not true by
the way they were against crooked
Hillary also something weird going on at
Fox our polls show us leading in all 17
swing states that's also a lie for the
record I didn't spend 30 hours with ABC
News but rather a tiny fraction of that
more fake news Bret Baier so there are a
couple of things going on here and one
of them is exactly as I predicted months
ago and this is something serious that
we have to talk about so that we all
understand it many of you if you've been
watching this program for a while or
listening to the radio show or podcast
you know that sometimes on fox news
shepard smith or chris wallace will say
something moderately rational they'll
tell some basic uncontroversial truth
they'll counter some obvious bogus right
wing talking point and it really
shouldn't be a huge deal when someone on
the news just tells the truth but on fox
news it sort of is a big deal because it
is such a disinformation echo chamber so
when i talk about it on the show I will
say it's good that Shepard Smith told
the truth it's good that Chris Wallace
told the truth
but it's a very low bar and we have to
understand that it's a very limited
opposition to an overall narrative that
is extraordinarily Pro Trump on Fox News
and the danger is that these little
instances of sanity on Fox can also open
the door for Fox to say hey look we are
fair and balanced we have multiple views
represented we have almost everything
and then on the other hand every once in
a while Shep Smith is allowed to say
something that's true now it's absurd
since a reporter Shep Smith for example
stating a fact shouldn't be considered a
balancing of the rampant right-wing
xenophobic propaganda that Fox is
riddled with but it does sort of open
the door for Fox to take some cover
under the fact that they have Shep Smith
and Chris Wallace now along the same
lines when Donald Trump calls Brett
Bayer fake news or at least Brett Bayers
report fake news that can similarly be
used to prop Fox up as hey they're also
getting slammed by Trump Fox is no
different they are under the microscope
by Trump just like CNN and everybody
else instead of the fact the real fact
the reality that the right wing echo
chamber propaganda network of Fox News
is 99% propaganda and as I said a few
months ago
depending on how 2020 goes Fox News
could abandon Trump Fox News is of
course committed to being right-wing
because that's what their donors and
their funders demand and expect they are
right-wing they will continue to be
right-wing but Fox News is not
necessarily committed to Donald Trump
Fox you might remember back in 2016
really in 2015 when the campaign started
Fox was not behind Donald Trump early in
the 2016 Republican primary there were
some big conflicts between Fox and Trump
early on now eventually when it became
clear that Donald Trump had growing
support that more and more of the
Republican establishment was getting
behind Donald Trump even begrudgingly in
some sense Fox ultimately got behind
Donald Trump if Trump continues to be an
utter and total embarrassment on the
world stage but it looks like he's gonna
win re-election in 2020
Fox will stay behind him but if it looks
like Trump will
fail as some early polls suggest he
might Fox News is not necessarily going
to stick with Trump they're about profit
and right-wing propaganda in a general
sense Trump might be the vehicle for
that propaganda but he also might not
and just to prepare you if Trump and Fox
have a falling out you need to know that
Donald Trump's network of choice is
going to become this absolutely wacked
out thing called Oh a n the one American
news network or one American news check
it out online but not with kids in the
room and not close to mealtimes because
it is truly it'll it'll turn your
stomach but Oh a n is where Trump will
go if ultimately he abandons Fox News as
the propaganda vehicle of choice make
sure you're following me on Instagram at
David Pakman and while you're there
follow the show on Instagram as well at
David Pakman show we will take a quick
break
boy it's a good program today glad
you're with me